good morning believe nation my name is
evan carmichael my one word is believe
and i believe that entrepreneurs will
solve
all of the major problems of the world
so today's message is
work on yourself over to you oprah
winfrey
i say to the my girls all of the time
that your real work
is to figure out where
your power base is and to work
on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give
with the real reason why you're here
that's that's the number one thing you
have to do is to work on yourself
and to fill your self up
and keep your cup full keep yourself
full
now i used to be afraid of that i used
to be afraid particularly from people
who say oh she said she's so full of
hassan
she's so close herself and now i embrace
it
i i consider it a compliment that i am
full
of myself because you only when you're
full i'm full i'm overflowing my cup run
is over
i have so much i have so much to offer
and so much to give and i am not afraid
of honoring myself you know
it's miraculous when you think about it
i really
love how oprah winfrey turned what was
intended as a negative of being full of
yourself
and she turns that into a positive and i
think it's such a necessary skill as
entrepreneurs
to take negative things and find the
positivity in it to find the optimism in
it to find the solutions in it because
that's how we stand out and succeed
i also really agree with the point on
developing and working on yourself
and this is where it can get really hard
it's easy to say i'm going to work on
myself it's easy to say i'm going to
work on improving this new skill or
learning that new language or building
that new business or whatever it is that
you want to
go out and do it's easy to say but it's
hard to execute
it's hard to execute because chances are
you're the only one
in your environment that actually cares
about it like say you want to be a
youtuber you look at all these youtubers
say i want to be a youtuber i want to
build a business on youtube i want to
have an
impact i have a message that needs to
come out i want to get my youtube
channel started
chances are you're the only person that
you know who wants to do youtube
and so it can be hard to stay motivated
because the people around you some of
them may be negative some of them retain
well you can't do that
you've never gone to school for that
what makes you think you can create a
youtube channel you kidding me do you
know who you are
that's great some people may be negative
some people though may just
not care and some people may be
encouraging but no matter how
encouraging they are
you are the one who cares the most about
this dream and when you don't have
the people around you who are also doing
the same thing
especially at a higher level than you
are it can be really hard to continue
and stay motivated what happens then is
you have a day when you're motivated
you're off and you're working hard and
you're creating your channel
you want to make a new video and then
you wake up the next day like
that momentum is gone you say who am i
to make a video i'm not very good did
you see what i did yesterday that was
terrible
and then you get inspired by something
else maybe you watch a video and then
you're on fire again like i'm gonna make
another video and you go off and you
create it
and then you fall off and so it's this
constant up and down ying
roller coaster yo-yo you know up and
down never really getting any
consistency in it
and so the key for me when there's
something that you really want to work
on
that nobody else in your environment
cares about is putting it into your
calendar and scheduling it out
if your goal is to have success on
youtube as an example or
insert whatever your goal is then
schedule it out
make time for it every single day that
you're spending time building your
skills
learning the language of that industry
to get better at it honing your craft
because on the days where you're on fire
motivated you won't need to schedule you
just be
you'll blast through it and just have
tons of productivity
but on the off days on the days in
between those spikes
the schedule helps you stay committed to
the goal that you have
the schedule helps you stay on path even
when you don't have
as strong a motivation to do the work
and so
i would look at what are your big goals
what is it that you want to accomplish
how do you want to work on yourself and
then look at your calendar
and do the things in your calendar map
to your ambition
are you doing the work in your daily
calendar that will help you achieve your
goals because for too many people
it's not two people have these big goals
and then you look at how they're
spending their time
they don't match up the work they're
doing consistently is not going to help
get them to where they want to go
and so those days of inspiration are
amazing but if you want to continue the
process and actually make real progress
towards achieving your goals
and really building yourself up then you
have to schedule it in
and make time for it to happen so the
question today today is i'm curious what
is the daily non-negotiable for you
what do you schedule into your calendar
every day at least during the week
weekdays that has to happen every day
non-negotiable
i'm curious to find out leave it down in
the comments below i also want to give a
quick shout out to margarita from
lovesome.com
thank you so much margarita for picking
up a copy of my book your one word
i really really appreciate the support
and i hope you enjoyed the read
so thank you guys again for watching i
believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is and i'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
i spoke at an education summit for
microsoft i also spoke at an education
summit for
apple at the education for my at the
education summit for microsoft
i would say that 70 of the executives
spent about 70 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat
apple at the apple education summit
a hundred percent of the executives
spent a hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite and the other one
is playing infinite gets which one gets
frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface
was incredible the design was
spectacular
i absolutely loved it it was easy to use
and it was
bright and gorgeous and fanta it didn't
work on itunes which is a different
problem
so i couldn't use it but but it was
amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant so i'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior apple executive sort of
employee number 12 kind of guy
and you know i like to stir pots so i
turned him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better than your ipod
touch
and he turned to me and he said i have
no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse the goal isn't to
be the best
every day the goal isn't to out to out
do your competition
every day that's a finite construction
if i had said to microsoft i've got the
new ipod touch and it's so much better
than your zoom
they would have said can we see it what
does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play to be better than
themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday
how can we create a product this week
that's better than the product we
created last week
we also have to play the infinite game
it's not about being ranked number one
it's not about having more followers on
twitter than your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself it's not about selling more
books or getting more ted views
than somebody else it's about how to
make sure that the work that you're
producing
is better than the work you produced
before
you are your competition and that is
what ensures you stay
in the game the longest and that is what
ensures you find
joy because the joy comes
not from comparison but from advancement
the concept of improving lives runs
through the center
of everything i do and then i realize
that
the the the way to improve lives is to
continually improve yourself
right so with that every every morning
when i when i get out of the bed
you know i i haven't fixed everything
in the world yet so there's always
something to do and uh in this film i
read
an interesting quote um for the
uh siddhartha gautama the buddha he said
that good people have to get
out of the bed every day and try to
empty the ocean
with a ladle right and i thought that
was
you know i knew that was profound and i
paused for a second
and i said all right what the hell is a
ladle right
right so that you know i just i touched
it on my ipad it's ladle oh it's like a
big spoon
a big spoon okay it's like a soup spoon
yeah
it's like a soup spoon i was like why
are you a soup spoon so try to empty the
ocean
with a soup spoon you know as the the
mentality of how you
you wake up every day to try to do good
in the world so for me i'm i'm uh i'm
really driven by
continually trying to um
elevate my elevate my mind and elevate
my spirit and care for my body and
um to be able to love as many people as
effectively
as as possible with this mystery